[Music]
don's in kansas city hey don welcome to
the ramsey show
hey love you guys and love the show
thanks for having me on sure how can we
help
well i got a question for you i'm 60
years old
i had to restart
everything i was at age 50.
i'm getting close to being debt free i
still have a student loan
forty two thousand five hundred and some
change
um
currently i'm i'm putting thirty percent
of my uh
my salary into a roth
and as soft as the market has become i
was wondering if i would be better off
cutting that back a little bit to say 15
of my salary and just attacking that
student loan
so 1500 a month
at it and knock it out in 30 months and
just be
totally debt-free or
uh how much is in your retirement in
this day
like i said i started over yeah
[Music]
you've been hitting it hard
yeah it's uh
a hundred thousand right now um but uh
in the past ten years
i've paid off uh 172 thousand dollars
worth what's your income
uh right now 55 in that period of time
between 40 and 55 okay so i i've been uh
i've been eating a lot of beans yeah
yeah so
yeah you've been in recovery you've been
in recovery mode good for you you're a
strong guy well here's what we teach don
the shortest path to wealth is to get
clear of debt first build an emergency
fund second and then start retirement so
we would teach you to temporarily stop
all
investing
and dump everything you can squeeze out
of your entire life on that stupid
student loan and get rid of it finally
because it won't go away
and then once it's gone we take
everything in the budget make sure you
have an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses how much is in your
emergency fund now
i know about seventy eight hundred
dollars okay all right i'm gonna bring
that down to one thousand dollars as
baby step one is what we teach
and so that's gonna give us 6 800 to
throw through the 42 000 and then we're
going to put everything entire budget
focus on the remaining 35 000 bucks and
you're going to knock that out very very
quickly
it's going to be about nine months
probably something like that you'll be
working extra you'll be beans and rice
rice and beans when the student loan's
gone then go back to the one thousand
dollar account raise it up to a fully
funded emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and then with not a
payment in the world and that nice
buffer you restart your retirement and
you hit it hard
and you start building build and build
and build in there and you're going to
be able to hit it even harder right now
you've got things going about six
different directions and they're not
giving you the power that they need to
give you hold on i'm going to send you a
copy of the book the total money
makeover to help you out